welcome get a keel test
you'll kill
the northern long sacks I'm Devin
chatterley I'm 29 years old I am an
active National Guardsman and I'm a
part-time bladesmith I need to come in
here gung-ho full Focus I'm ready to
become the next Porsche fire Champion
the northern long sax is a single edge
blade widely used by Vikings and
northern European tribes during the
Middle Ages
it's razor sharp edge and pointed tip
were useful in slashing as well as for
thrusting allowing the user to deliver
heavy blows and stabs to finish off an
opponent in close quarter combat
although used as a deadly weapon the
Vikings would also use the sacks to hack
tree branches and skin animals
today The Versatile blade can be seen in
Netflix historical drama series The Last
Kingdom
the Viking battle ax
my name is Ryu Lim I was born and raised
in the Philippines I'm an iron worker
and I make blades for a living the
Viking battle ax was a brutal killing
weapon that played a significant role
throughout history Viking warriors were
mostly Farmers so when going off the
fight they would pick the tool they had
close at hand which was often a wood
cutting ax when later models took on
shapes more convenient to the Fighting
Man the battle ax was born the haft was
made of wood and the curved head allowed
the ax to be used to hook an opponent's
ankle throwing him off balance and onto
the ground positioning the Viking to go
in for the kill with the large
razor-sharp Cutting Edge the battle ax
has a long and colorful association with
fantasy film and literature being the
weapon of choice for the dwarves and the
Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit as well
as for the players of fantasy computer
games such as World of Warcraft
today I'm working on Northern long socks
I'm really excited to get this going get
this thing cooking what I'm gonna do
today is I'm gonna start this Damascus
spill and get everything forged welded
and drawn out and I actually plan on
getting the blade completed today oh my
gosh
I noticed that a concave going up to the
drop point so I'm going to to start
drawing out that metal wide as possible
because I need this to make parameters
there we go that's the one I was looking
for I couldn't be more proud
to start on the handle I'm going to cut
up some aluminum bar stock or the pommel
the threads
all right
now it's even more snow and on my
handles a bit plain and Bland but at
least it'll be shiny I just want to make
sure this weapon will perform so at the
end of the stay I will be testing it as
much as I can
okay here we go
[Laughter]
slice right through I got my blade done
I'm very happy with it it cuts it kills
it's pretty much perfect
the studio shop had everything man I got
the Bare Bones only the the basics my
Forge is basically a cast iron pot with
a hole drilled in the bottom where I
attached a black pipe and on that black
pipe I attached the hair dryer
using the hair dryer I introduced more
oxygen and the more oxygen you put it
the hotter it gets I'm gonna stretch out
the metal and I'm gonna wrap it around
the pipe to make an eye for the handle
I really have no teeth because it's so
big it doesn't fit in my Forge I had to
make some adjustments to remedy that
when you're working with high-powered
power tools you gotta remember safety
first
yeah where's my protection
and respirator
the way it's going right now I'm not
getting enough Heat
I'm losing a lot of heat very quickly so
I might start over or make a new Forge
the first Forge wasn't working because
it was too small
so I added a satellite dish around it so
I'll be able to add more coal and make a
bigger fire
it's looking good right now I could move
on to the fun part
is this forging this
Viking act the firefighters came and
unfortunately I was delayed an hour your
biggest thing we gotta deal with is in
fact it's too close to the boat
I have to move the forage and reposition
everything
hopefully it doesn't affect me too much
towards the end
I don't have electric sauce I'm gonna
have to carve this down
I spent the last hour pounding in the
handle at the same time making it
it was tough but I'm just really curious
what the judges are going to say really
a battle ax doesn't have to be smooth
and shiny it just has to work it doesn't
have to be pretty to split skulls
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do I will take your
weapon deliver some lethal blows on this
big carcass all right Dapper Devin
you're up to you ready sir I'm pumped
let's do this
[Music]
nice
thanks man
all right Devin let's talk about your
weapon here
the blade you have here is nicely
balanced that when I cut the weapon does
not do the work for me I do the work
with every slash as you can see I cut it
down twice all the way through overall
sir your Northern log sacks
little Keel thank you sir the teslie
felt if your ex I will strike the side
of beef here and see what kind of damage
it does
Ryu you're up next you ready
I'm ready let's do it
the hand is a little slippery so first
couple of tries it was slipping off I
had to make sure that it didn't go fly
off my hand I
you cut about
three end into the fourth bone
this I believe
is a killer
good job thank you very much
bladesmiths Welcome to our strength test
fittingly for this Arctic challenge
we're gonna do the ice block chop
it really tests The Edge holding and
overall construction your knives it's a
lot of fun too let's do it
foreign
test your access will be placed on the
specially designed impact device
arm is set to deliver maximum Force at
the point of impact we will deliver
three strikes on the shield
that will give us a good indication of
how much pressure your ax can take
let's see if your weapon will survive
this test Ryu three two one engaging
[Applause]
engaging
let's put the shield in half and all the
way through
Edge held
path is still secure
good job
forged in fire war of weapons